[CLICKING]
[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
PROFESSOR: Why is it so hard for
some people to recognize faces?
Is a pterodactyl
really a dinosaur, and
what does that have to do
with ethics in computing?
Are GMOs helpful or
harmful, and how do we know?
Is calculus a language?
Welcome to Chalk
Radio season three.
This season, we'll talk
with more MIT professors
about the passions that fuel
their cutting edge research
and innovative
teaching, of topics
like neurocognitive
science, climate,
laboratory chemistry, computer
science, and many more.
So tune in to hear
candid, funny, serious,
and personal conversations.
And as always we'll share
links in our show notes
so you can find our guests' open
educational resources on MIT
OpenCourseWare.
Chalk Radio, it's the
closest thing to being here.